let's talk about how to accelerate data
power innovation within your enterprise
we will look at some of the key
challenges that enterprises face and a
five-step journey that we have seen lots
of successful businesses take to get to
data power innovation we look at what
enterprises encounter along the way and
discuss our Google cloud can help with
examples hello and lack Lakshmanan I
leave analytics and AI solutions at
Google cloud what are some of the key
challenges that enterprises face
especially when it comes to data well
firstly and probably the most important
is the size of data the amount of data
in most enterprises is growing
dramatically 20 to 30 percent
year-on-year such that an e-book back
after five years you're looking at about
a 5x increase in the amount of data and
it's not just the size of the data by
2025 a quarter of that data that you
have is going to be real-time nature and
as you know real time data is harder to
manage and maintain then historical data
in addition much of the data tends to be
unstructured and today less than 1% of
unstructured data is analyzed or even
used and so these are some of the key
challenges when it comes to data and
technology that's used to to work with
the data and then put in place the
environment that we're in today and you
have unprecedented market ships and so
you need to be able to analyze the data
processed data increased velocity and
scale if you want to power data power no
innovation to your data and so lots of
enterprises are driving their
data-driven business transformations
using Google Cloud so whether it's
businesses in retail or gaming of
Central Services and all over the world
whether in the Americas or India or
Japan and AIPAC we have experience
helping leaders and all of these
companies bring about data rate change
and this consists of a five-step process
and the first step is to stop the
bleeding you need to reduce the cost of
managing data especially as the data
sizes grow dramatically and one of the
ways that you do that is by migrating a
data Lake and data warehouse to the
clock once you have your data
centralized the next bit is to break
down silos within your organization
build a data culture to democratize
analytics and once that once you have
everyone within your organization able
to access the data process it the third
stage of the journey is to be able to
make decisions in context faster Rena
beyond time I'll talk about what I mean
by in context but once you're in this
place where you're basically doing
descriptive analytics as as well as
possible it is then time to move on to
predictive and prescriptive analytics
and at that point the first step the
journey is to look at end-to-end package
AI solutions to leapfrog so that you're
not building everything from scratch
you're able to take advantage of what's
already available in the marketplace and
finally to be able to empower data power
innovation that is truly differentiated
by building an operationalizing AI so
let's walk through each of these steps
and talk about what enterprises
encounter along the way and some of the
things that we have to do the first step
as I said is to find the budget to carry
on data powered innovation and in order
to do that you have to lower the cost of
ownership
you have to simplify operations and so
that is the first stage on the journey
to carrying out a Orbitz innovation the
problem is that your traditional
enterprise data warehouse
implementations they hinder business
transformation first of all they can't
scale fast enough to keep up with us 5x
growth in data that we talked about and
secondly as 25% of the data when it
comes streaming
it becomes really important that all of
your queries are on fresh data and you
need your data to be fresh and that is a
problem with a lot of enterprise data
warehouse implementations thirdly we
talk about breaking down silos and
building a data culture it is extremely
important to make sure that you do that
in a secure way then and oftentimes the
way that security is done is it provides
data access restrictions that inhibit
collaboration between different parts of
your enterprise and of course the cost
of maintaining and by the cost we don't
just mean the software costs a license
costs but also the cost of operational
ISM so you're basically spending a lot
of time tuning the data warehouse rather
than getting insights from it and
finally we want to make ourselves ready
to carry out machine learning and AI and
that is also something that
traditionally DW implementations kind of
hinder
so that's the reason why a lot of
industry leaders rely on Google Cloud
when it comes to modernizing your data
whether it's Home Depot who wanted to
accelerate the time to value or Zulily
who needed to be able to get instant
insights for all of their offers that
they're create dynamically on Hearst
Newspapers wanted to use advanced
predictive and analytics AI or
AccuWeather which is looking at sharing
data not just within their organization
but with all of the partner
organizations and their share and those
kinds of insights with ease and doing
all of this in a secure way which they
know you want to be able to protect data
operated trust as HSBC does the
technological capabilities of Google
cloud the fact that our data warehouse a
server less is self-tuning
that we offer you high performance
streaming ingestion that every sequel
query is automatically streaming in
nature that you can operationalize
machine learning without ever moving
your data out of the data warehouse this
is what allows you to modernize your
data architecture and of course all of
this is set up from the premise that you
need to find budget to carry out your
data innovation and that budget
you're gonna get because by migrating to
the cloud we can lower your total cost
of ownership massively so oftentimes
more than a 50% reduction and cost but
it's not just about the data warehouse
because data platforms and data rolls
are converging and they need to
interoperate so when we talk about a
data warehouse and in a warehouse today
functions often as a data Lake also so
where we traditionally used to have
extract transform and load these days
you just extract and load directly into
data warehouse and from there you
transform as necessary and if you have
Hadoop workloads in your data rake you
want those hurdles to be able to read
data from your data warehouse and vice
versa you might have queries in your
data warehouse doing a federated query
on your data link so your data leak in
your data warehouse we need to be
interoperable and form the common data
platform and this is true not just to
the technology it is also true to the
perspective of the people who are going
to be using the data so whether it is
data analysts using business
intelligence tools or data scientists
using a data science platform or machine
learning scientists and data scientists
using tensorflow and machine learning
they all need to be able to access data
whether it's the data lake or whether
it's in a data warehouse that
interoperability and this ability to
build a data platform that combines both
the data warehouse in the data layer or
extremely important and that's the way
that we've designed Google Cloud State
about form so our idea is that you need
to be able to derive a return on
investment from your data link so that
it's a business asset and not just an IT
cost so all of the things that I've
talked about in terms of modernizing a
data warehouse they applied to a data
Lake as well you want to get large-scale
performance you want to do this is lower
cost you want to be able to reduce your
operational complexity you definitely
want to make sure that your practical
data that it is secure that you're
breaking down data silos between
different parts of your domains
and using AI to extract value from all
of your unstructured data so whether
it's Pandora or our Institute or Metro
all of these people are building data
lakes for their unstructured data for
their semi structured data and for their
hadoop workloads on google cloud such
that it is the business asset and for
example done hundy had a blog where they
talked about how they were able to move
from their traditional monolithic Adu
cluster to ephemeral clusters by
ephemeral we mean a cluster that is job
specific and get a cost savings of over
75 percent so again the idea of moving
your data lay in the data where of the
reason that it's your first stage in
your journey is that it opens up the
budget to do all of the best of the
innovation that you want to do and in
order to help you do that
we have a lower-risk offer to migrate
and modernize your enterprise data
warehouses and your data leaks so if
it's a data warehouse we have ways to
virtualize and translate your queries
automatically and optimize and reduce
your cost if it's a data link we have
ways to different shift and then move
towards ephemeral clusters and then
moving into a completely serverless
system once you have moved your data
warehouse in your database the cloud the
next step is to look at how to
democratize data access and build a data
culture in your organization to talk
about the kind of benefits it can take
for example HSBC where they had to
calculate the liquidity position of a
country it used to take them 10 hours to
do but they were able to do it in less
than 30 minutes they were able to do
financial crime analytics using bigquery
10 times faster but the reason they were
able to do all this was because they
were able to move their workloads to GCP
such that all of the teams around the
world has access to capabilities to help
them innovate so we see the result of
the innovation but the reason that that
is possible is because of this
democratization and of the breaking down
data science and if if you're a company
that need to move your
to the cloud you want to make sure that
you're moving it in such a way and
breaking down your data silos in such a
way that you have strong security and
governance controls right especially
when we talk about whether we want to
basically provide access to data for any
team who can access it who's allowed to
access it you want to make sure that all
of your data is encrypted in transit
ingressive there's not a bucket out
there that somehow left open that you're
able to bring in your own encryption
keys that you're able to use cloud DLP
for classifying and impacting sensitive
data are you able to discover data that
all of your data that you're putting in
the cloud is subject to third party
audits and certifications if you need to
be HIPAA compliant that you can be here
for compliant and finally that if
someone accesses the data there's access
transparencies where you can go look at
the audit logs and you know who has
accessed it when they access it and by
the accident so when you're moving data
and you want to make sure that your data
is available to a broad set of your
organization one of the key problems is
how do I know what data I have and
that's where data catalog comes in we
have a simplified data discovery
mechanism such that you can go ahead and
find what data sets you have and data
catalog has built-in governance that you
can for example say things you can tag
pieces of data and on not necessarily
entire tables not necessarily entire
data sets but just columns and say these
columns are sensitive data and you can
cover and sensitive data across the
organization in a simple straightforward
consistent way but one of the things
that happens is as you build your data
warehouse on the cloud you start to
centralize your data bring your data
from sa P from terror data from Oracle
from YouTube and Google Apps and you
centralize them into the data warehouse
the data warehouse on Google Cloud is
called bigquery
once it's centralized there what many
organizations find is that they start to
see analytics
so rather than carry out the analysis in
the data warehouse itself
you see people taking extract of the
data throwing it into spreadsheets
throwing me to the dashboards and all of
these things start to become slightly
out of date so the next step is to look
at how can we do analytics in a modern
way and the way to do that is to apply
governance and control to your KPIs and
so we're looking at modern bi and
analytics subsets you can have
dashboards with tiles that are shared
across your organization reports and and
self-service definitely but all of their
self-service reports and exploration
take advantage of centrally built KPIs
and this allows you to take insights and
embed them into web sites and existing
applications and also build data-driven
workflow some customer applications with
it so it's one thing to centralize your
data but you also need to look at how do
I centralize the analytics on the data
how do I make sure that those analytics
themselves are reusable instead of
everybody writing their own excel
formulas of everybody writing their own
ciphers and this is again something that
a lot of our customers have found great
benefit and Credit Karma for example
says there used to be a lot of Excel
spreadsheets floating around and now
it's audun looker program under common
governance or Autotrader talking about
democratization of how they will in a
matter of weeks able to go from nothing
to something that was usable but all of
your sales squats so the third step then
so the first step is to move your data
to the cloud second step is to open up
access and build a data culture and the
third step now now that there is now
everyone has access to the data the
third step is to be able to make
decisions in context faster and with
real-time data so one of the key things
when we talk about context is the
location is incredibly important when we
look at tabular data from most
enterprises we see that about 15% of
tables tend to have
information under store locations
customer information etc and you need to
be able to do accurate spatial analysis
within your data warehouse you don't
want to have a separate your spatial
database and that's one of the key
things that you can do this that you can
unless GIS data will fill your sequel
part of your dashboard and be able to
incorporate location information because
location is incredibly important context
the second big piece of context is
stannum so real time data is very very
very valuable so there is a big
difference between being able to act on
and on a three days later or being able
to make a decision on and own within a
matter of minutes and or within a matter
of seconds real time is real value and
but there's an e-commerce or in gaming
or manufacturing or in retail you want
to be able to make decisions as quickly
as possible and in order to do that
again we start with the data warehouse
but the key thing to realize is that in
the data warehouse and Google Cloud
every sequel query is automatically
streaming so all of the investments that
you have done to get to the point of
democratizing access and building
dashboards and building common analytics
all of these actually work in real time
as well what we need to do is to make
sure that they're ingesting transforming
and enriching the data and streaming it
into the data warehouse and that's
something that we do naturally it
flowered because both pops up and data
flow just like requiring or all
serverless they are very easy to operate
very low cost and you can spend all of
your time getting insights from the data
rather than on operationalizing and on
on the IT infrastructure of building a
messaging system or building a data
exists and once you have your data in
the data warehouse you can do machine
learning directly the data warehouse you
don't have to move your data out of the
data warehouse and this
you to carry out machine learning as
part of the streaming analytics
pipelines for things like anomaly
detection for example and this is
learning credible benefit because
normally when talk about machine
learning we're talking about a data
science team that has to eradicate all
of this data and whenever you replicate
data you run into a security issue right
you have two copies of your data
floating around so bickering machine
learning baby allowing you to do machine
learning directly in your data warehouse
enhances your security posture enhances
your access transparency and this is
exactly what a VJ see for example it was
able to do they have 25 user sessions
per day they need to analyze 50 billion
banks and they wanted to make better
decisions and obtain increased revenue
and in order to do that they needed they
were able to basically fertilize access
to large volumes of data within their
company to basically carry out
operations so at this point in the
journey you have the ability to have a
data culture to be able to make
decisions in context spatial context
temporal context and then the next step
is to say okay how can we now do more
prescriptive analytics and at that point
you want to say you want to look around
the marketplace it's not necessarily
that you have to delete every piece of
AI you need what can you buy because
when you buy you can leapfrog and Google
Cloud we have we have lots of readily
embeddable AI marre so for example if
you want to process video and you want
to do video classification or action
recognition or object tracking you don't
need to go build this from scratch we
have an API you can use and you can use
it directly and in your applications for
it or for example if you are into
translation and you don't need to go
build your own translation model
Bloomberg for example
and you use article comes in they need
to send a global update to 40 in 40
languages to over 170 countries and they
do that we go back to it and so the idea
here is that Bloomberg is quite capable
of building their own translation model
but they did instead what they did was
that they bought it and similarly right
if you want to improve the performance
of your contact center there are three
things that you want to be able to do
you want to be able to look at standard
queries and automate them as much as
possible and if a query is handled by a
call center agent you want to make sure
that that parade that's handled the
first time correctly you want to improve
their customer service of your support
organization by providing the call
center agent all of the information that
they need as soon as they need it
and finally you also want to use the
support calls that are coming in to
understand the business manner and this
is the game something that you could
build from scratch but why do that when
you can leap from the head with the
contacts centralized solution room to be
plowed and that's what Ticketmaster does
for example or that's what Marks &
Spencer does where they basically take
advantage of our contact center AI
solution to improve their customer
service similarly if you have forums and
you want to extract information from the
forms one form parsing you could build
it from scratch or you could use a
document AI solution and leapfrog ahead
and allow us to basically carry out all
of the hard work of doing natural
language processing and building then
for example if you wanted to claims
processing here's an insurance company
that was able to use a document AI to
get an incredible reduction in the
claims processing and settlement time by
again leapfrogging so the key thing with
AI is to think about what kinds of
things do I need to build them what
kinds of things can take time and when
it comes to buying AI models you want to
buy AI models that are high quality that
are that have been no battle tested and
that's something that you can get out of
our platform the fifth step then at this
point you
you have prescriptive analytics but the
prescriptive thing that you have is
primarily things that vary by the last
step of the journey to doing the ADA
power innovation is to empower your data
and Sheen learning teams and give them
the tools for them to be successful so
let's step back a bit and think about
faith I talked about leapfrog in with AI
and I were about to about a custom AI
and the idea is that in in your
organization you're gonna have a
portfolio of business use cases not
everything needs to be built from
scratch and not everything in Canada
bought so you need to look at your use
cases and maybe make a determination of
those use cases on 3criteria
how faster you wandered how much effort
do you want to put in and how much
differentiation does this business offer
and based on that it allows you then you
choose whether you want to use a fully
prepackaged AI model or B you want to
take a bunch of building blocks and
combine them in a bespoke way or do you
want to build custom AI that is fully
fully differentiated and regardless of
which of these you want to do we have a
platform that allows you to do it that
gives you the ability to do it and we
can partner with you to help you on this
journey of others using the a
out-of-the-box are building up on top of
our building blocks like after Emma and
the Curie ml and the vision API etc or
whether you want to do custom ear but
the idea here is that you will have lots
of applications that are collecting and
storing data into the data Lake and data
warehouse that is a first part of your
journey to doing data power inhibition
and having done that then you basically
arm your data science teams to be able
to build and use AI when building use AI
regardless of whether it is AI out of
the box of building blocks or custom AI
being able to take it experiment with it
generate insights from it but once you
start to see that this data science team
is being successful in the development
phase you need to have the
to promote it and operationalize the
machine learning and that's what we call
Emma laughs to be able to do this
routinely to be able to monitor and
retrain the model when the model's start
going out of sync because of changes in
the environment of the data and that for
example eBay for example uses custom AI
third part of my model whether you want
to do visual product search and at that
point the training an image classifier
on 55 million product images getting a
10% increase in image recognition
accuracy in 10% is an incredible
increase in accuracy been able to do
that 10 times faster because of the
amazing hardware called GPUs that are
available on cloud again Google cloud
incredibly differentiator in terms of
both our data platform and in terms of
our IT platform so when you are taking a
journey to enable data power innovation
within your organization we can help you
derive value our every step of the
journey whether it's to reduce TCO in
the first stage whether it's to
democratize analytics in the second
stage whether it's to be able to make
higher value decisions in the third
stage whether it's being able to
leapfrog your competition in the fourth
stage or being able to really create a
Frenchie ated transformative AI in the
fifth stage we are happy to work with
you at every step of the journey thank
you